con sus manos consiguen rescates
imposibles de entre los escombros y han
aprendido a celebrar cada Victoria en
medio de la catástrofe la organización
de defensa civil Siria conocida como Los
cascos blancos Son los únicos trabajando
día y noche En búsqueda de
supervivientes de los terremotos que
devastaron buena parte del norte de
Siria barberos panaderos bomberos
estudiantes convertidos ahora en
experimentados rescatistas y entrenados
durante más de una década se formaron en
2013 Durante los años más sangrientos de
la guerra civil Siria después de cada
bombardeo del régimen autoritario de
bashara lazada sobre ciudades Rebeldes y
opositoras eran ellos quienes acudían a
ayudar a la población civil sobre todo
menores dejando registro en las redes
sociales de sus rescates El dictador
sirio y sus aliados Rusia e Irán
llevaron a cabo una campaña de
desprestigio y criminalización con
ataques sobre sus instalaciones médicas
provocando el exilio para muchos de sus
integrantes
como Los cascos blancos por ejemplo que
son al qaeda son del frente al nusra que
se afeitan la barba llevaban sombreros
blancos y aparecen como Héroes
humanitarios
el grupo de unos 3000 rescatistas está
financiado por países como Reino Unido
Japón o Estados Unidos y han recibido
formación en el extranjero en 2016
fueron nominados al Premio Nobel de la
paz sin éxito pero lograron el Nobel
alternativo y un año más tarde un
documental sobre su trabajo se llevó el
Oscar sin más armas que sus manos y
teléfonos móviles han sido también
críticos con la comunidad internacional
y su papel en el conflicto sirio que en
marzo entra en su décimo segundo año en
la nieta si la comunidad internacional
no responde y aborda la crisis
humanitaria creo que todo el mundo
pagará el precio
bajo el lema extraído del Corán salvar
una vida es salvar a la humanidad dicen
haber salvado a más de 99.000 personas
que ahora se suman las víctimas de los
sismos mientras continúan apelando al
mundo entero para el envío de ayuda
humanitaria